Hi, I'm Toby, and welcome back to the joy
of mathematics. It's been a minute since I
filmed one of these, but I'm so glad that you're
joining me again today for a relaxing journey
through mathematics. I'm going to run some things
across the bottom of the screen that we will come
to understand in this video. But mostly, we
will be learning how to escape from reality.
Some people do this through drawing,
painting, reading or playing video games,
we are going to get a private tour of an imaginary
world with the help of my imaginary friends.
Before I introduce you, let me tell
you a story. When I was six years old,
I remember a kid in my class at school, saying
that there were secret numbers that only he knew
about. He said that the teacher had told him about
them after class, that they were less than zero,
and called negative numbers. I was doubtful.
I hadn't ever heard of such things.
I thought that if it was true, then the
teacher surely would have told all of us.
Maybe I felt a little hurt that
she had picked a favourite student,
or that I was missing out on something. Perhaps
that's why I still remember all these years later.
Of course, I eventually found out that negative
numbers were real. But I had another similar
experience several years later, in high school
math class, we had a relief teacher one day,
I think it was the careers counsellor. He
spent the start of the hour following our
teachers lesson plan. But towards the end veered
far enough off course, that he said, Have you
guys heard of imaginary numbers? We hadn't.
With animated strokes, he drew a large axes,
and labelled one real and the other imaginary.
After that class, I felt pretty Mind blown.
Maybe I was yet to really understand
them. But that was the first I heard
of these mysterious new numbers. I had again
experienced my view of numbers being expanded.
A long time later, I would realise that
negative numbers and imaginary numbers
are in fact, similar in the way that they extend
mathematics. They are both somewhat intangible
ideas that prove to be useful. Where the negatives
come from asking what one minus two might equal
the imaginary unit i comes from asking what the
square root of minus one might be if it existed.
Now it's in the best interests of you and I to
acknowledge that we live in the real world. And
our actions have real consequences. So we should
try to be nice to each other. I will introduce
you to my imaginary friends now. And whilst this
isn't a popularity contest, we will want to keep
track of how many imaginary friends we have. At
the moment we haven't met any. so we can write i
to the zero. And it's one of those quirky
little mathematical facts that anything to
the power of zero is equal to one. This solution
is our passport. And since one is a real number,
we're not going anywhere. And we have to stay
out here in the real world. But meet my first
imaginary friends, Ignatio, with him, we
have i to the one which is equal to i.
So without first friend, we can now travel
from the real world to the imaginary world.
It's wonderful in here, but now I'm
trapped. How can I go back to reality?
My second imaginary friend, Iguana
can help. With two imaginary friends
we have negative one. I'm back in the real
world. But this is the negative real world
and it's so sad out here. I could get help from
a real friend who is negative such as minus one.
But there's not really anyone out here. I could
instead get help from two more imaginary friends.
With three imaginary friends in total,
we are taken back to the imaginary world.
But we end up being underground. And
a fourth imaginary friend in total,
will bring us back out to the positive
real world. Right where we started.
This is all you need to know, to travel
between our world and the imaginary world,
we can show our story on a map, where we're
jumping between the points one, i, minus one
and minus i. And that is because multiplying by
i is a rotation of 90 degrees. If the friends
we met had been a gang of negative numbers, then
we would have toggled between one and minus one.
This flipping shows that multiplying by
minus one is a rotation of 180 degrees.
An imaginary friend takes us to a pit stop in
between to have a timeout from reality. Because
multiplying by i is a rotation of 90 degrees,
then if we do it twice, we get to negative one.
And if we do it four times, we get back where
we started, we could of course go the other way
as well, we would see a clockwise rotation
of 90 degrees if we multiplied by minus i.
This ability to multiply and move around in a
circle is what makes imaginary numbers so good at
modelling things that are circular in nature, or
that rotate. And despite the name, they are not
imaginary at all. Some people just have trouble
seeing them. And whether you want to believe
in imaginary numbers or not. They are right
there. A second dimension to every number.
It says mind boggling as decimals
or a rationals would have been
to early mathematicians. Some never got to
know there were numbers in between one and two.
Larger friends such as two i, three i, and
four i, allow us to go anywhere on these axes.
But what about the rest of the plane? Well, yes,
we can travel anywhere we like. It's just a little
bit more complicated. This is the complex plane,
after all, in the rest of this region, we need
two parts, a real part and an imaginary part. To
explain where we are. With one foot in each door
here at one plus i, we are halfway
between worlds, a rotation of 45 degrees.
Let's see a use for multiplying complex numbers.
Say you go for a walk in the forest,
but you end up getting a little lost.
At first you walk along the path laid
out in the direction of eight plus two i.
But you realise this isn't right, and you want
to change your track by 45 degrees. How would
you work this out? Well, normally, you could do
some trigonometry, some sine and cosine. Maybe you
need to carry a protractor with you to work out
the angles. Or you can multiply eight plus two i
by one plus i, which we already know is a rotation
of 45 degrees. Eight plus two i times one plus i
is equal to eight plus eight i plus two i plus two
i squared. Since i squared is equal to minus one,
that term becomes equal to minus two, and we end
up with six plus 10 i. So walking along the path
laid out in the direction of six plus 10 i, will
be an offset of 45 degrees from the original path.
Introducing imaginary friends has given us an
extra dimension in which to travel and a useful
tool for performing rotations. These friends might
become a dime a dozen as you go on and maths,
but each one is still special. I'm proud of
the friend who appears in the wave function of
the electromagnetic wave. The electric field and
magnetic fields are perpendicular to each other,
and their magnitude and time variation are
correlated. by assigning the magnetic wave
to the imaginary part and the electric wave
to the real part, we can explain these two
waves in one equation and capture the way that
the sum of the two individual waves rotates.
To meet some more imaginary friends to head over
to Brilliant, who have kindly sponsored this
video. Brilliant is a place to learn in a fun and
challenging way. And while there you can meet my
pals Julia and Mandelbrot in a course on complex
numbers, they will guide you through the rest of
the topic with visits to complex multiplication,
polar coordinates and the most beautiful Euler's
formula. It's great that you're on YouTube now
sparking your imagination by watching math videos.
But to solidify your knowledge as real, the best
thing you can do is to try problems for yourself.
Brilliant's website and app are built off the
principle that you learn best while doing. They
have something for everyone. So if you'd like
to join me and a community of 8 million learners
and educators today, click the link in the
description below or visit brilliant.org/tibees
Safe travels to your imaginary world. I hope
you have an absolutely mathematical day.
Thank you to my Patreon supporters, and a special
mention to today's Patreon cat of the day Mina.